l a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vigile ed oggi siamo su un
nuovo video reaction ho scoperto ragazzi
una cosa nel mio canale di youtube c'è
una sezione che si chiama riconoscimenti
di cosa si tratta in poche parole una
persona fa un video e se nel video ci
sono altri youtuber gli crea un
riconoscimento insomma dimette link
sotto 30 youtuber mi hanno messo tra i
riconoscimenti vediamo che gli più
persone una vagonata di video di una
persona che si chiama visto avvistato
vediamo di cosa si tratta ragazze il
primo v cosa nasconde fa vj incredibile
favi j1 youtuber che grida sempre bella
tutti i ragazzi c'è uno tipo che dopo
sei anni fa miliardo di video horror
divertente alterno miliardo di serie
blog parodie è caratterizzato con questa
frase 1 youtuber chi grida sempre bella
tutti i ragazzi ben attenti ragazzi
bella tutti ragazzi bella tutti ragazzi
è così per tutti i giorni 10 minuti di
video tutti così ma cosa nasconde questa
frase composta da quattro parole e 18
lettere ma a parte questo ma che cosa ci
fa gianluca vacchi versione zombie sullo
sfondo spiegano nasconde qualcosa di
mostruoso inizio dicendo che fa vj ha 22
anni
fin qui tutto bene poi sommiamo 18 più 4
che sarebbero le lettere e le parole che
compongono bella tutti ragazzi 18 più 4
fa 22
proprio come gli anni di favi jane
bastardo scoperto nel librone
dell'apocalisse di youtube c'è il numero
22 che sta ad indicare il giorno in cui
fra vj renderà in possesso la
piattaforma youtube sono scoperte ci
stanno tracciando prima che aspetta che
è un'altra coincidenza a minchia vabbè è
nato nel 2005 si è lo slogan iera
broadcast yourself se la frase broadcast
yourself è composta da 17 parole
fammi capire se tu riordini le lettere
broadcast yourself esce fuori bella
tutti ragazzi si fa come tom riddle
lodging voldemort guardi sommando 17 più
5 cioè il numero 5 indica la data di
nascita di youtube viene fuori 22 quindi
fa vj entro il 7 aprile
riuscirà a rubare youtube per usarlo in
modo malefico ci ho messo tutta la vita
per arrivare a questo mondo senza che
nessuno se ne accorgesse questo spiffera
tutto ti credi di essere fin dall'inizio
i fondatori di youtube misero nel
librone nero dell'apocalisse youtube ica
il simpatico tra virgolette fa vj ma io
posso leggere lo sto libro
dell'apocalisse youtube e che non ho
ancora avesse bisogna contrastarlo in
qualche modo per prima cosa è opportuno
fare tanti video contro fa vj bisogna
bruciare il libro dell'apocalisse
youtube ica in una montagna del new
mexico precisione a in the uk e archi
queste infine bisogna pronunciare le
parole fa vj sommo fa dj tu non puoi
fare quello che vuoi perché potresti
diventare
basta ed era solo uno dei mille video in
cui mi ha incluso sto tizio dato sono le
11 e 22 quando sto guardando questo
video 11 e la metà di 20 220 222
tra tutti questi video abbiamo anche
dissing rap contro fa vj visto avvistato
sempre lui vediamo un pò ciao a tutti io
sono visto avvistato perché farò un
dissing contro fa vige mi stai chiedendo
che cos'è questo questo è il microfono
dove nella quale canterà la canzone che
sentirete sarà una canzone rap
convincerò parlando di youtube fa vj
sulla strumentale dice sciocca ma quale
dj così farò più viva solo taglia copia
incolla premi play metrica banali ticino
ci riuscirei vado adesso in uno stato
non ho voglia di vedere fa bj peccato io
ho detto sono brutto avvistato lo
youtuber molto amato lui non mi ha
risposto e mi ha guardato io compare
attonito male l'ho guardato dj
dimmi se ti basta anni basta va bene
così comunque nella mia vita io ho
sempre desiderato vedere un uomo che
canta con un uccello che è una frase
bruttissima però ve lo giuro in questo
caso si parla di questo non ce lo
compatisce d'altro canto è un modo per
scherzare sono mister è educato fermi
fermi fergie era iniziata la videocamera
e nel mettere che cantava aggiustata
l'inquadratura bellissimo era la vj
d'altro canto è un modo per scherzare su
piazza ne accorge bellissimo però non
maltrattiamo gli uccelli per cortesia
già che gli hai aiutato in faccia per
tutto il video almeno non monterario e
cazzotto porino tra tutti i
riconoscimenti che ci sono ce n'è uno
che è anche molto particolare la
minaccia di parigi e delle facebook star
fino all'anno scorso c'era un solo
protagonista indiscusso per le ragazze
delle fiere cioè una ragazza si avvicina
al curi a caso a capo dal nulla e lo
bacia sulla riva l'anno scorso c'era un
solo protagonista e noi sorpresissimo di
questo genio da dove dado bucks era
conteso da cosplayer anche ad ora erano
vestite da carte napolitano perche la
gas perché ne veronafiere vestito da
carta napoletana l'est cosplay aver mai
visto un cosplay cosib e certi che rojas
i fattori studentesse di hogwards
profero tutte che solo limoni il
successo di queste facebook stare ignoto
fa vj e il successo di favi ma con che
capelli e la cosa più bella di questo
fotogramma non sono io ovviamente ma è
la fascia al tizio dietro e il successo
di fa vj è un mistero
è una tecnica che va avanti da millenni
bisogna fare un video secondo un ragazzo
che piace sia ai ragazzi che ai loro
genitori
lui ha un grande potere sulle ragazze le
sconfitte ra ma non è vero
l'unica maniera per fermare fa vj e
parlo di perdere la memoria
in altre parole spa raf lasciarlo stile
men in black
[Musica]
ecco perché non mi ricordo più un cazzo
dal 2015 in giù mi aveva spara flashato
i tempi comunque ragazzi io non vorrei
dire ma avevo il mio fascino il like
avevo veramente de l'equipe tutte per
terra è per carità le stendevo che era
un piacere ma signore e signori come
torta sotto la ciliegina io andrei a
vedere le verità oscure di favi jayce
tecnici cio gamer e tutti quelli che
puoi mettere nel titolo per fare clic
bait ci rimetti inizia dicendo che i fan
i geni è una stola massa si ecco perché
ogni tanto perdo te cosa che mi dicono
adesso portando il male prima fra i gay
è uno scolapasta
non ci crederete mai così se prendiamo
le elettriche sono le s ii che era
centrata lascalaunder30 dedurre che i
familiari è uno scolapasta comunque
ragazzi vorrei anche spezzare una lancia
a favore di queste persone che si
inventano queste storie ma in realtà mi
divertono un sacco quindi non ho niente
contro di loro e contro chi mette il mio
nome nei titoli per ragazzi vi sia
piaciuto però ci concludo quale video
come mi piace che resta fermi nel
cristiani socialisti fischiati e noi ci
vediamo ad un prossimo mistero o cose
del genere
beh ragazzi cioè fammi capire c'è
qualcuno che si è ritagliato il mio
video con al bano
[Musica]